okay today I'm going to talk to you
about gamma rays so gamma rays are part
of the electromagnetic spectrum if you
have a look at the electromagnetic
spectrum you can see that gamma rays
have the highest frequency now this
means that they transfer the most energy
making them what is referred to as being
highly ionizing this means that they can
damage cells what we're going to look do
is we're going to have a look at some of
the different properties of gamma rays
now because gamma rays are part of the
electromagnetic spectrum they travel at
300 million meters per second which is
the speed of light that's around that
speed in a vacuum they're also a type of
transverse wave
so the first use of gamma rays were
going to look at is their role in
sterilizing now all that sterilizing
really means is to kill microbes such as
bacteria now there's two main kind of
sub categories of this that we need to
know about so first of all they could be
used to sterilize foods so here's just a
little diagram of a strawberry now the
whole purpose of doing this is again to
kill the microbes within the food to
keep the food fresh for longer without
having to freeze it so what what they do
is they bombard the the food with this
gamma radiation and because it's highly
ionizing because it carries so much
energy it actually kills lots and lots
of these microbes allowing the fruit to
be fresh for longer now it's not just
food that we can sterilize it's also
gamma radiation or gamma rays are
extremely useful in sterilizing medical
equipment as well so let's say this is a
scalpel they can sterilize medical
equipment to again by emitting loads and
loads of gamma radiation and it's highly
ionizing it can kill all of the microbes
involved next up another use of gamma
radiation
is for medical imaging now what that
means is this person here might have a
tumor might have cancer but we might not
know exactly where that tumor is so this
person could be injected with something
which is called a tracer now what the
tracer does is it actually emits that
means it gives out gamma rays or gamma
radiation now they might have abnormal
blood flow particular part the body so
let's say they've got a tumor right here
so what mate what will happen is they'll
have more blood flow containing the
tracer to this particular part of the
body and the tracer gives out gamma
radiation gamma radiation can pass right
through the skin so it could be texted
outside the body and then the doctor can
look for any abnormalities so like I
said this medical imaging specifically
can be used to detect things such such
as cancer as well as other things as
well but cancer is a very very big use
so if we can diagnose this person they
can get the medical support that they
need much sooner the final use that we
need to know is cancer treatment
oops smudging it a bit sorry is cancer
treatment so what I'm drawing here this
is the top of someone's head and they're
lying down so these are their shoulders
and so their feet are going kind of down
into the pages at the top of their head
here so let's say unfortunately this
person has got a brain tumor they've got
a tumor right in there in their brain
now we might not be able to operate
because we would be damaging the other
parts of their brain it might be a deep
brain trigger that we can't operate on
so instead what we can do is really
really clever what we can do is we can
actually basically fire lots of gamma
radiation at that tumor
and this is how it works so if we've got
the gamma radiation coming from all
these different angles you can see that
they all converge that means come
together over the tumor so as a result
remember gamma rays are highly ionizing
which means it can kill these cancer
cells making up this tumor and kill the
cancer cells however it can be a little
bit risky because obviously this
person's the rest of their body is also
being exposed the rest of their cells
are also being exposed to the gamma rays
so ironically even though we're killing
the cancer cells we could also ionize
the other cells in the body causing
cancer however this might be the only
option notice how all of these different
these gamma rays converge come together
over the tumor so these cells are much
much much much more likely to be damaged
than the rest of the cells in the body
similarly with this one here even though
this person's admitting the tracer emits
gamma radiation
the tracer has what's called a very
short half-life which means it's the
radioactivity or the amount of gamma
it's given out decreases over a short
period of time and stops over a short
period of time so that basically is
gamma rays and the different uses thank
you